welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and with Doctor
Strange about to take us into the
multiverse of madness it's time to break
down everything we know so far about the
upcoming movie throughout this video
I'll be discussing the film's release
date its tie-in to the Disney Plus shows
the meaning behind its title what kind
of hair gel Benedict Cumberbatch uses
and what the plot leaks about the movies
say will happen in it basically
everything now there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything from the film potentially ruin
for you then I highly suggest that you
turn off now I'll give you another
warning when we get into the leaks at
the end of the video but if you don't
want to know anything at all then now's
the time to turn off without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness okay so firstly
the upcoming MCU movie was announced at
San Diego comic-con at the Marvel phase
4 panel in Hall H earlier this year we
got the likes of Black Widow the
Eternals shang-chi and more confirmed
but the most interesting film for me out
of the bunch was Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness Kevin Feige who
hosted the panel stated that the film
would be directed once more by Scott
Derrickson
who was at the helm of the first movie
and that it would be released on May 7th
2021 though it seems so far away
due to all the other announcements at
the panel we still have a lotta Tidus
over including some Disney Plus shows
that will tie into the movie which I'll
get into later as for the film itself
the movie is currently being labeled as
marbles first-ever horror film though we
don't know what will happen in the
Disney Plus shows prior to it at the
aforementioned panel it was stay that
this will be the first movie in the MCU
that will tackle the multiverse directly
whilst the multiverse was a huge plot
device in spider-man far from home with
Mysterio claiming to be from another
earth this was revealed to be a lie
which had some fans thinking that it was
just a cooler easter egg however at the
faceful panel kevin feige himself said
that this doesn't mean that it does not
exist so we do know that this film will
deal with alternate versions of
characters and scenarios that played out
differently to the already established
canon
title itself is actually a reference the
infamous HP Lovecraft novel titled at
the mountain of madness throughout his
long and rich history strange has
tackled many of the creatures that
Lovecraft created due to his work now
being out copyright and it appears that
this film will take a similar form it's
definitely an awesome nod to the book
and those who are fans of Lovecraft's
work will know that there's a lot to
choose from
however a major center around the work
in which the film draws its title from
at the mountain of madness follows an
expedition group that discover uncharred
areas of Antarctica and unwittingly
unearth a long forgotten civilization
and an alien race that exists there the
book went on to inspire classic horrors
like the thing and there's a wealth of
potential to pull from here if marble
decides to use elements of it now what
this could mean for the characters is
that the MCU heroes and the venturing
into unknown areas of the multiverse and
through this they unearth a dark
creature that wants to ravage reality
I'll get into how this ties into the
plot leaks later but recently Kevin
Feige also discussed how the Disney Plus
shows were required watching if you want
to go into the film and knowing all the
ins and outs
when asked if both Loki and one division
were tying to the movie he said I'm not
sure we've actually acknowledged that
before but they do so this confirmation
makes it seem like we are gonna need a
Disney Plus subscription to understand
exactly what's going on I'm kinda in two
minds about this as I do think it's a
smart move by Disney to make people
subscribe to their new platform if they
want to watch the MCU going forward
however I also feel like it may a Lee
innate certain fans who may not be able
to afford it or aren't fully up to speed
with how subscription services work my
grandmother loves the MCU and has all
the movies on blu-ray but I can't see
here checking out Disney Plus especially
since she doesn't have the internet
anyway shoutouts Nana death she's not
she's not deaf that my name is
definition anyway from this point onward
in the video I'm going to be discussing
the plot leaks that we have for both one
division and Loki and whilst these won't
be fully confirmed until we see the
shows for ourselves there may be some
big spoilers here so now's your last
chance to back out are you still here
okay good so according to the pot leaks
that have apparently come from people
that are working on the show one
division the series will take place
after the events of Avengers and Game
and center around a depressed Wanda
Maximoff after losing the love of her
life and her brother she tries to adapt
to the new world but finds it so
difficult a mysterious woman named
Agatha will offer a helping hand by
showing her how to create a pocket
dimension similar to the mirror world in
Doctor Strange where she can live out
her life happily ever after alongside
vision and her two newborn babies named
Wiccan and speed this draws heavily on
the vision graphic novel by Tom King and
will take many of its plot devices and
the style of the overall work Agatha
will then appear in the pocket dimension
to try and kill wonder when their
children grow older which they do after
merely a week has passed in this
dimension there are also said to be
several major cameos with Ultron and
Quicksilver both making appearances the
leaks say that Benedict Cumberbatch will
show up for the final episode after the
dimension grows out of control and
splits into its own multiverse and this
will segue into the movie as for Loki
this will apparently be a time-travel
journey in which the character goes
through history rewriting all of his
defeats after he managed to escape
custody in Avengers end game similar to
Wonder vision this leads to a vastly
different timeline being created to the
one that we know and love and though
there is no mention of Doctor Strange in
any of the leaks he may pop up similar
to how he does in one division to try
and right the wrongs that the trickster
has created now unta Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness and all of the
plot leaks that we have on that though
we haven't had any confirmation of the
villain there are rumors that the evil
entity nightmare is set up to be the big
bad of the movie with casting directors
currently deciding between you and
McGregor Christian Bale and Matt Smith
nightmare is the ruler of the dream
dimension which is an area that humans
are brought into during their sleep to
be tormented and tortured scarlet which
creates the multiverse of madness after
falling under the influence of Nightmare
who reminds her of how good her pocket
dimension was after Doctor Strange shut
it down this creates the grand plot and
the movie revolves around strange who
must rescue her to prevent the collapse
of reality the film is also set to pick
up on the post-credits scene of Doctor
Strange in which Mauro had started his
mission of destroying sorceress the fact
that there are fewer wizards in the
world has been pointed out in infinity
war when strange wasn't really joined by
any others when fighting the forces of
darkness and later in n game when Wong
arrived strange
ask is that all you could get this kind
of cements that more dough has been
successful in his mission of murdering
so many and whilst Wang who took over
the position of sorcerer supreme and
strangers absence probably thought that
this was due to the snap the fact that
they are not there at the end confirms
this Mordo also sees just how close to
collapse the universe is and strange
manages to convince him to come and help
save reality strange assembles a team of
sorcerers including Wang the previously
mentioned Mordo clear and drum strange
omoro clash on whether one that can be
saved or must be executed and this adds
drama to the proceedings strange and
clear developer bond & 1 & drum have an
unlikely friendship
now whether Loki will be present in here
or not we do not know but the fact that
his show is crucial to the events of the
film I wouldn't be surprised if there
was a cameo of some sort in here with
the character the film apparently ends
with the group rescuing skull at which
but this comes at a big cost with her
wishing mutants into existence which
allows the x-men to enter the MCU
this is the opposite to the comic book
house of M in which the character wished
the majority of mutants away and this
time it's flipped around to create them
rather than destroy them now we are
definitely getting to the point where
the MCU needs to start thinking about
how they are going to bring mutants into
their universe and this kind of makes
sense on some levels I'm not 100% sold
on this final leak as I don't know
exactly how it works but with the
inclusion of Deadpool right around the
corner it does seem like the Marvel
Universe needs to retain some aspects of
the Fox franchise and bringing them
through the multiverse is a great way to
do it
whatever happens though I am really
excited for in the multiverse of madness
as it has the potential to be amazing
and we've already seen in films like far
from home with the Mysterio illusion
scenes that Marvel definitely has the
skills and technology to produce a
mind-bending horror movie that alters
the very perception of reality that the
characters have the film does sound
incredible from the tidbits that we know
so far and it's great to see that the
MCU is slowly drifting away from their
formula to discover new areas in the
universe that will totally shift the
balance of the film's going forward I
can't wait to see what in the multiverse
of madness is like and needless to say
I'm very excited for the film's release
in 2021
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie and what you're
most excited to see
comment below and let me know and if you
love this video 3000 then please give it
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
my breakdown of the new big Disney Plus
release the mandalorian which would be
linked at the end we go over everything
that you need to know about the show
give our theories on the final scene and
discuss the easter eggs you missed so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey well head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the marble
phase 3 part 1 box on blu-ray which
contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming Ragnarok and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on Doctor Strange 2 in the
comment section below
the one is gonna be chosen on the 15th
of November and the set will be shipped
out from the end whoever gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you